alors pour préparer cette cérémonie j'ai
été amené à rencontrer beaucoup
d'acteurs et d'actrices et c'est vrai
que j'ai été souvent frappé par le
décalage qu'il ya entre entre l'image
publique qu'ils ont est ce qu'ils sont
vraiment dans la vraie vie vraiment
parfois il ya un gouffre et c'est vrai
que bon j'ai rencontré récemment une
icône du cinéma français je m'en faisais
tout un monde
et en fait elle n'est pas du tout comme
vous croyez
joe commerciaux monaco avec mademoiselle
adjani
bonjour postiches en découd avec la même
énergie
[Musique]
oui oui bonjour bonjour c'est le
prestige et vend des blouin
deuxièmement ça excuse moi entre genres
souligne qu'orange c'est dingue
oui ou non qu'ils aient déjà
réinitialiser mais ça marche toujours
pas oui oui
adjani à des gis à ny1
oui je patiente territoire je vais vous
tuer hb je faisais sol
[Musique]
pardon je me suis fait les patchs
pelletan déjeuner tu as mangé
oui oui c'est bon tu vas café je veux
bien enfin si vous avez un tu me tutoie
je leur dis moi qu'est ce que tu voulais
me proposer oui alors en fait je voulais
vous parler de la cérémonie des césar
mais merde ya eu 2 est à il faut que
j'appelle monop pour la livraison
je publie les reprendre la norme est pas
grave moi je m'en passe un petit nas le
vide
escaré nescafé pardon j'étais ailleurs
oui maintenant je les dis à votre
collègue
et oui bien sûr je me suis débrancher
rebrancher mais ça change rien je
patiente s'assure donc en fait je
voulais savoir si vous vouliez remettre
un prix non mais c'est pas grave sinon
c'est quand cette année le laisser d'arc
c'est le 28 février
as tu février non je peux pas je suis en
déplacement je peux pas annulée c'est
c'est trop important
moi je comprends vous êtes au festival
de berlin annoncé en même temps
non pas du tout j'emmène mes neveux
center parks j'aurais trop mit center
parks bah oui tu sais c'est les vacances
pour la zone alors j'ai réservé du 22
février au 29 février ou trois forêts en
moselle
je connais trois fours alors je ne
connais pas sous la piscine a voulu il
adore bien sûr qu'il n'aime pas les
laits piscine à boules eux
oui oui oui pendant 15 secondes
j'essaie côté monsieur donc moi je veux
bien de brancher encore une fois si vous
voulez mais cette fois je vous garde en
ligne
bon je vais peut-être vous laisser
isabelle hains vous voyez les airs et
ans mais sinon ça risque de prendre des
heures
merci en tout cas pas au revoir et bonne
chance à merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci mais j'espère
à
je suis con avez menti vous nous avez
arrêté privé vous allez vous calmer elle
est partie en atterrissant dargaud mais
tu as tu
camille sée la camisole la tension je
vous dis que les partis mais là je suis
pas fan vous savez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]